hi I can see as soon as we start filming
the shyness yeah
well it's like interviews are always so
diff it's so different than like the
creating and like being in the studio
and just like writing and stuff and then
it's like okay and then after the music
comes out it's like okay sit in front of
camera with really bright lights and
like how can be serious and like
sometimes it's like I you feel like you
have to be perfect but um I think
sometimes like I was just thinking
myself and like you seem like really
cool chick like let's just have Girl
Talk
yeah my tea
you got your tea you look so adorable
yeah I was thinking about that because I
was I was listening to your new album
and it well first of all there were
moments there was like some sexy songs I
was like okay like we're a grown woman
now like you're doing sexy but to hear
like that side but it's such a great
album and thank you you you do really
get personal so what is that like for
you to you know write these records and
then the music comes out and then you
have to perform something personal talk
about something personal
what's that like for you well I've been
doing this now since 2002 and this is my
sixth album and I didn't hold back I
just opened up and of course I write all
of the songs and like there were a
couple songs in the back of my head well
I'm writing them it's like am I gonna
get asked like who is this one about but
now it's I'm at a point where it's like
I don't I can open up and write about
anything I need to write about or would
like to write about but I don't have to
like you know get down exactly what it's
about I just kind of throw myself out
there I really wanted to be honest and I
feel like that's the type of music that
people connect with because it's like
the intention behind an energy around
and everything it's like it's real it's
true and
I think that music is like it can move
people and it's healing and powerful and
they've had like a lot of feedback like
in the past of my fans are they're like
you know they tell me how much the songs
need to them so what I'm writing I just
put everything into it in hopes that it
will like inspire people and be you know
have a positive impact on Pete other's
lives yeah you can hear it it's
definitely it's definitely inspiring I
really like how you just spread
awareness for Lyme disease so I know
nothing about it but I learned so much
just through you and then just studying
you know what you're going through
being that this is the first new album
in five years five years of that was
spent with you having three years of
that was spent with you having Lyme
disease how has your outlook on life
changed um well I'm glad I had like as
much fun as I did in the past like I
used to always like live every day like
it was the full like Bella to the
fullest like it was my last day so I
look back and I'm like ah I'm glad I've
really embraced my career and just like
life and that was always my approach and
that still is my approach today do I
look at things differently yes and no I
mean I think that I appreciate the
smaller things and the things that were
taken away from me at one point I've
come so far and like when I turn around
and look at where I was as in to where I
am today like I fully have my life back
and I'm so appreciative and grateful and
um I feel like I always was though and I
always had a really good head on my
shoulders and worked really hard to get
to where I was like I was just like this
chick from a small town in Canada I got
here on my own with like no connections
so I always felt really focused and
hardworking I think if anything there's
the small things and random things are
just so much brighter yeah now but I
also think that
that just comes with like life
experience yeah - and as we grow we
appreciate different stuff more does it
affect your relationships and
friendships with people does it doesn't
make that difficult um I think I got
this point in my life I just really know
who my friends are and I like to keep
like a close small group and yeah I
learned a lot about friendships and
learning how to like lean on people and
I just keep good people around me I
don't have you know time or energy for
anything other than just good solid
people I love that I feel like Canadians
just know right people just like no I
feel like I can like read people like
right away - I get like a set it might
be Canadian thing really do you think
that you've been open about you know
your support group and how awesome
they've been I know you said your mom
your dad your boyfriend your friends
even Chad which i think is amazing
but do you think that you would be here
today if it weren't for that support
group
um yeah like no I mean yeah there were
certain people my life that really had
to step up to the plate yeah I know it
sounds strange although like Chad and I
separated he was like still there with
me the whole time and we're still really
close and um no my mom my dad my brother
my sister-in-law and a few of my friends
in LA everyone's you know been really
great I feel like I've um really good
people around yeah now yeah um I mean I
actually find it inspiring just you
saying like oh I you know I'm working
with my ex and we're fine and whatever
but I find that inspiring because a lot
of people they don't get along with
their exes yeah it just says a lot about
your character honestly no just to be
able to still have that kind of
relationship and even be able to work
with them yeah so what's that like for
you um I feel like I just talked about
Chad so much because everyone always
brings the buzzing
great and yeah we still work together
and um yeah yeah I guess at this point
you know we've been through a lot
together and he's still family and I
love him and the band his band and I'm
like a huge supporter of Nickelback and
he's he's awesome he's he's a great guy
and like it's really cool cuz like I'll
write a song and then I'll be stuck and
I'll call him up or I'll bounce an idea
off him what do you think at this and I
love writing songs with him he's so busy
I hardly get to see him but like if he's
in LA I'll be like let's write a song
that's so cute um I know that you said
that before too that you're a fan of
Shania another one of our Canadian gems
we spoke to her about Lyme and she said
that it affected her vocal cords and
really and she had to get treatment and
stuff and obviously your voice sounds
phenomenal on this album so did that
ever become a concern I think your
singing voice getting affected and I
think that while I was recovering I
thought it was the first time I'd ever
had real time off so um yeah I was
concerned when I would start singing
that maybe my voice because it's a
muscle would be like not as strong but
you know I was just really so passionate
about the songs and when I got behind
the mic and I sang I was just so there
and so present just like energetically
and spiritually and just like everything
and like I open my mouth to sing and I
feel like I've kind of singing better
than ever you are but like it's like
it's everything it's because like I'm
just so um I'm so in love with music all
over again I'm not doing it because I
have to I'm writing music and recording
and performing because I want to because
there is a love for it and like through
this entire experience of like getting
sick and going down and not being sure
whether
I was going to be making music or not
and like coming turning to music really
showed me how much I really do love it
and need it in my life
you